>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THINGS MOVE FAST IN THE AOC
GENERATION.
HISTORY IS 2017.
FOR A LITTLE PERSPECTIVE WE WILL
TAKE YOU BACK 29 YEARS.
STILL A MODERN ERA.
WE HAD AIR-CONDITIONING AND AIR
TRAVEL.
IN 1990, 2,545 PEOPLE WERE
MURDERED IN NEW YORK.
THE HIGHEST NUMBERED RECORDED
EVER.
IT WAS THE PEAK OF THE WORST
CRIME LEG IN OUR HISTORY.
RUDY GIULIANI WAS ELECTED AND
MAYOR AND POLICIES CHANGED AND
CRIME BEGAN A STEEP DECLINE.
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG BECAME MAYOR
OF NEW YORK OF THE NEXT YEAR AND
MADE NEW YORK EVEN SAFER.
ONE MAN TOOL WAS STOP AND FRISK.
THE NYPD WOULD STOP SUSPICIOUS
LOOKING PEOPLE AND ASKED THEM
QUESTION AND SEARCHED THEM FOR
WEAPONS AND ILLEGAL DRUGS.
NOT EVERYONE LIKED IT EVER, BUT
THERE IS NO DEBATE ABOUT HOW
WELL IT WORKED.
IT WORKED WELL.
BY 2013 NEW YORK CITY REPORTED
JUST 333 MURDERS TOTAL FOR THE
YEAR.
IT WAS AMERICA'S SAFEST CITY.
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG WAS PROUD OF
THAT AND PROUD OF STOP AND
FRISK.
>> TODAY WE HAVE FEWER GUNS,
FEWER SHOOTINGS AND FEWER
HOMICIDES.
IN FACT MURDERS ARE 50% BELOW
THE LEVEL THEY WERE 12 YEARS AGO
WHEN WE CAME INTO OFFICE.
SOMETHING NO ONE THOUGHT
POSSIBLE BACK THEN.
THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT STOP
AND FRISK SAVED COUNTLESS LIVES.
WE KNOW MOST OF THOSE LIVES
SAVED BASED ON THE STATISTICS
HAVE BEEN BLACK AND HISPANIC
YOUNG MEN.
>> Tucker: NOT JUST MOST BUT THE
MAJORITY HAVE BEEN IN THAT
CATEGORY.
THAT WAS 2013.
NOT THAT LONG AGO.
YOU MAY REMEMBER 2013.
BUT TODAY MICHAEL BLOOMBERG IS
TRYING TO WIN THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINATION.
YOU THINK A PARTY THAT CLAIMS TO
CARRY ABOUT POOR PEOPLE WOULD
REWARD ANYONE WHO MAKES LOW
INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS SAVER, BUT
NO THEY HATE HIM FOR IT.
>> THIS IS A POLICY THAT PUT
BLACK AND LATINO MEN IN PRISON.
-- SAFER.
>> THIS IS A MAYOR THAT PROVIDED
OVER AN ADMINISTRATION THAT DID
STOP AND FRISK ON EVERY BLACK
AND HISPANIC PERSON.
>> HE RAN NEW YORK CITY LIKE
OLIGARCH.
>> STOP AND FRISK WILL BE THE
PROBLEM FOR MICHAEL BLOOMBERG.
>> HE STILL DEPENDS HIS POLICY
OF STOP AND FRISK WHICH IMPACTED
FAMILIES LIKE MINE.
MY COUSINS AND FRIENDS WERE
STOPPED ON THE NEW YORK CITY
SUBWAY SYSTEM AND RACIALLY
PROFILED AND PATTED DOWN.
>> Tucker: OH, YEAH.
IT AFFECTED ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ'S FAMILY.
SHE GREW UP IN WESTCHESTER
COUNTY NEW YORK, A TOWN THAT IS
MORE THAN 90% WHITE BUT SHE SAYS
IT'S RACIST.
AND MICHAEL BLOOMBERG AGREES
WITH HER.
LAST SPRING HE BLASTED JOE BIDEN
FOR AN APOLOGY TOUR WHERE HE
BEGGED FORGIVENESS FOR EVERY
GOOD IDEA HE SUPPORTED.
NOW IT'S BLOOMBERG'S TURN TO DO
THE SAME.
>> I GOT SOMETHING IMPORTANT
REALLY WRONG.
I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND BACK THEN
THE FULL IMPACT THAT STOPS WERE
HAVING ON THE BLACK AND LATINO
COMMUNITIES.
I WAS TOTALLY FOCUSSED ON SAVING
LIVES BUT GOOD INTENTIONS ARE
NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
BACK THEN I WAS WRONG.
I AM SORRY.
>> Tucker: I WAS FOCUSSED ON
SAVING LIVES.
THAT'S WHAT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
IS MAKING HIM SAVE.
THE REMARKABLE PIECE IS THAT
THIS SAME MICHAEL BLOOMBERG WHO
JUST APOLOGIZED FOR STOP AND
FRISK IS THE SINGLE MOST
AGGRESSIVE AND FREE SPENDING
LOBBYIST FOR GUN CONTROL IN
AMERICA.
HE WOULD DISARM SUBURBIA
TOMORROW.
NOW HE IS TELLING YOU IT WAS
IMMORAL FOR HIM TO THE NYPD TO
TAKE THOUSANDS OF ILLEGAL
FIREARMS OFF THE STREET OF NEW
YORK.
THIS IS CONFUSING.
WHAT IS THE REASONING?
THERE ISN'T ANY.
POLICIES LIKE THESE AND THEY ARE
POPULAR NOW FROM ALLOWING DRUG
ADDICTS TO SHOOT UP ON THE
SUBWAY, THESE POLICIES ONLY MAKE
SENSE WHEN YOU UNDERSTAND THE
BIGOTRY OF THE LEFT.